we're continually being bombarded with
suggestions about what we might do go
jet skiing study in Colorado visit the
Maldives or set up a tech company out
west the modern world makes sure we know
at all times just how much is going on
out there it's a culture in which
intense and painful doses of FOMO or
fear of missing out are going to be
inevitable there are two ways of looking
at this romantic or classical to the
romantic temperament missing out causes
immense agony somewhere else
noble and interesting and attractive
people are living exactly the life that
should be yours you'd be so happy if
only you could be over there at that
party with those people working in that
agency of Washington Square or
holidaying in that Shack in Jutland
sometimes it just makes you want to
burst into tears the romantic believes
in the idea of a defined Center where
the most exciting things are happening
at one time it was New York for a few
years it was Berlin then London now it's
probably San Francisco and in five years
it may be Auckland or perhaps Rio for
the romantic humanity is divided into a
large group of the mediocre and a tribe
of the elect artists entrepreneurs the
edgy part of the fashion world and the
people doing creative things with tech
as a romantic it's exhausting inside
your soul your mother sometimes drives
you nuts
her life is utterly dull how can she
accept it why isn't she a Qing to move
to the Bay Area
she's always suggesting you take a job
in Birmingham or inviting you on a
walking holiday in the Lake District
sometimes you're quite rude to her you
avoid certain people like the plague
that shy friend from school who
struggles with their weight the flatmate
who's a telecoms engineer and wants to
go into local politics being around
individuals who are so unglamorous and
lacking in ambition can feel pretty
fatal for their part
classically minded people acknowledge
that there are of course some genuinely
marvelous things going on in the world
but they doubt that the obvious signs of
glamour are a good guide to finding them
the best novel in the world they like to
think is probably not currently winning
prizes or storming up the bestseller
lists it may be being written at this
moment by a
Hritik woman living in the otherwise
unremarkable Latvian town of Lea pooja
classical people are intensely aware
that good qualities coexist with some
extremely ordinary ones everything is
rather jumbled up lamentable taste in
jumpers is compatible with extraordinary
insight academic qualifications can give
no indication of true intelligence
famous people can be dull obscure ones
can be remarkable at a perfect launch
party drinking sandalwood cocktails at
the coolest bar in the world you could
be feeling sad and anxious you might
have the deepest conversations of your
life with your aunt even though she
likes watching snooker on television and
has stopped dyeing her hair the
classical temperament also fears missing
out but it has a rather different list
of things that they're afraid of not
enjoying getting to truly know one's
parents learning to cope well with being
alone appreciating the consoling power
of trees and clouds discovering what
their favorite pieces of music really
mean to them chatting to a
seven-year-old child as these wise souls
no one can indeed miss out on such
extremely important things if one's
always rushing out a little too intently
to find excitement elsewhere heading off
in haste to that stylish bar with a
see-through elevator packed with some of
the city's top creatives
you